talk about the new movie about time I
really enjoyed this film and I have to
say I was very impressed more redheads
in this movie than in any movie I think
I've ever seen it's like you went out of
your way to Only cast redheads and I'm
very hurt I think I'm the only redhead
alive not to be in the film
that's okay I'm so sorry I could have
been we had a tall redhead already there
I know I saw him in the film yeah and I
was the whole time I was watching I was
saying to my wife that could have been
me and she said you're a terrible actor
and I went that's not the point
um yeah so there is a there is I think
single-handedly you've done a lot for
the the redheads we've got all the
redheads there sorry except you yeah
yeah yeah all the important ones yeah uh
there's a scene they're all redheads yes
or like Auburn these beautiful children
we've got about 18 different kids and
they were all well because when you use
young kids you have to have
many many backups right because a kid
can only work for like an hour and then
he has to go and take a nap right and
they get away too you gotta have backups
just in case they escape
where's that baby took off an hour ago
they do if they find out that they're
parents are somewhere because their
parents have to hide because if they see
the parents are like oh no I'm going
over there I'm not staying here with you
lady I want to be with that lady over
there I mean you can't we try to bribe
them with food and nothing nothing money
a one-year-old with money
uh there is a scene in a in a restaurant
that uh is I I think this is these
restaurants really exist because I've
seen them but there's a scene where you
uh and uh the character that you end up
I don't want to give away too much but
you two end up having a romance and
um you meet in a restaurant that's
completely blacked out where people
can't see their food have you ever been
to one of those before
we actually went to one as a as a little
field trip as a test run for the film
um Richard Curtis brought the cast who
is in that scene um to a place called
Don Lenoir in London and
um yeah it's it's pitch black like it's
an abyss and the whole idea is are not
supposed to be able to see what you're
eating you're it's it's total nerve you
just are you're eating and obviously
it's very good food but you don't know
what it is right no clue and it's
supposed to heighten your senses but I
went with the veggie surprise because
that sounded the safest to me because
you can have fish surprise or meat
surprise and so I suck with veggie and
and I thought that would be so easy but
it was so difficult to figure out what
you're eating and even to get your fork
to your mouth yeah so do a lot of are a
lot of people like taken away from the
restaurant with a fork in their cheek
I would be I would just that's what
would happen to me I'd be taken out
immediately with like just various Forks
in my head what are you doing aggressive
eater yeah I'm very I've eat quickly
and with the lights on it's a lot of
quick jabbing
and I jab those around me
when you when the group hits the street
does everyone just have food all over
their faces like that was great yeah
it's just covered in gravy just caked in
food yeah yeah but no one can see
anything when they come out so it's fine
I mean it really is like what it would
be like to be blind you you you're
looking grasping for any Shard of light
and there's there's nothing so it's just
a really strange experience but it's a
fun scene in the movie it actually it
was intrigued after I saw the movie I
thought I'd like to go and try that out
I think I could do it I think I think
it'd be a great way to do speed dating
yes because you don't you're not
distracted by you're really you can
focus on the person because you're right
not you're not thinking uh completely
about what they look like you're
thinking about who they are as a person
yeah and you can meet with your hands
and get away with it they won't you
won't be judged if you're just
I've been out with Andy a lot and that's
what he does with hot soup he does it